I have to get right to it you
experienced something I'm I'm confident
that I can say I will never experience
you went to a white tie affair at
Buckingham Palace did indeed in England
in London England Buckingham Palace I
have no idea tell us what this event was
was like it is it's like doing The Love
Boat man it is
no Jamie Farr did the love
meeting that there is no disappointment
in the experience of course yeah what I
mean it's everything it's cracked up to
be you get this you get this pamphlet
that says how you're supposed to dress
and how you're supposed to address
people how you supposed to put on
clothes you women can't show their
shoulders or wear open-toed shoes I
don't know why I think the people who
have have had their heads cut off yeah
and uh you know the white tie and Tails
you know yes the the jacket comes out of
here and you have a vest underneath you
are not supposed to show any vest under
your coat and you think well am I going
to be a resident and then you get there
and everybody's got their vest hanging
out and the little ladies are wearing
open toe shoes everywhere and you're and
when you meet somebody you're supposed
to address them as Sir or ma'am and you
get there and they pay no attention to
the protocol it's like hello I'm Julie
this is my husband Craig and Julie is a
baroness and Craig is the counselor of
the ex Checkers right right you know so
do you think it's almost a prank do you
think they're giving you the 50 pages to
learn and then they're like the
Americans
yeah the the and the the even right down
to the dinner I think they put Americans
next to you as a joke like if you if
you've been a good English person you
get to sit next because we know nothing
we don't know what we don't know what
glass to pick up we're not sure what
these courses are we ate all this food
and I'm sitting next to somebody and uh
the devious up the two ladies they were
both baronesses or duchesses or
something like very nice ladies and the
conversation is called the convivial but
we have no idea what to do and we
finished what I think was about our
ninth course and this bowl of uh
consummate was brought to us a clear
broth constant man I think well
obviously you drink you eat this
consummate with a spoon in order to
clear your palate for the Royal cheese
sorry why would you assume there'd be a
royal cheese
because it's Buckingham Palace
and um obviously there's going to be a
cheese course so I'm getting ready to
clear my pallet for the Royal cheese and
I pick up my spoon and I'm dipping it
down into the clear consummate and the
the baroness next thing goes ah
spoon goes flying and she said what are
you doing I said well obviously I'm
clearing my palate
with the consummate for the Royal cheese
and she says that's water to wash your
fingers with
all righty then why because they're
going to bring some fruit and after you
eat the fruit then you will need to wash
your fingers then I looked around of
course everybody had moved their
consummate off to the play and what's
what's amazing is that Rita was down
sitting next to the former prime
minister in James Bond's boss a little
farther than my wife my wife the actor
who plays James no no no literally the
guy hello I'm Don I run MI5 oh my gosh
yeah the real God the real The Bona Fide
spymaster who was a very handsome dude
on top of this and an unemployed and an
unemployed politician the guy and she
had the same problem did you almost
drink that soup the consummate I said
yes
it was a royal consummate
then then we then we don't they don't
tell you what's happening you don't know
how many courses are so we don't know
when the dinner is over have no idea but
then we hear off of the distance
somewhere deep within the bowels of
Buckingham Palace bagpipes that get
closer
and closer and closer until the doors
burst open and 40 bagpipers come into
there
[Laughter]
and they go all they Mark all the way
around this huge room and you just watch
and it's the loudest noise you have ever
heard and then they stand at the back of
the room and they play a full song but
back in the back of the room it's a
little quieter
[Music]
and then they pick up again and then
they March all the way around and then
the queen and the Royal uh uh Entourage
they get up and leave with them and so
we all stand up because the queen is
leaving and without knowing it the staff
pulled the chair outs from behind you
and move them to the center of the room
so we're standing there quietly as the
queen walks out and the bagpipes are
receding and the baronessity don't sit
down
why because there's no chair there
anymore
and that's the sign that dinner is over
and you go off and you have to wait an
end to dinner man oh man I tell you our
American heads would just swimming
swimming do you think through through
the dinner she's thinking will I tell
him about the chair or what time
sure
[Laughter]